We are in the year 1886.
Carl Benz and Gottlieb Daimler independently invent the automobile:...
...Benz in Mannheim and Daimler in Stuttgart.
In 1900, businessman Emil Jellinek orders a totally new...
...and particularly fast car from Daimler.
It is to be named after his daughter, Mercedes.
At the race week in Nice, this car wins one race after another.
And this means that from 1902 on,...
...all passenger cars produced by Daimler are called Mercedes.
Driven by this success, the Benz company also begins to build new and faster cars.
As times become difficult for businesses, the two companies come together in 1926.
A new brand name is born: Mercedes-Benz.
With 160 vehicles, the Mercedes-Benz Museum in Stuttgart...
...tells the entire history of the automobile.